[Music]
I'm Phyllis Bennis I'm a fellow at the
Institute for Policy Studies I don't
think that it quite works that way if it
did Operation Cast Lead with 1,400
Palestinians dead so many children
killed and injured the destruction of
vast infrastructure the use of chemical
weapons like white phosphorus all
playing out on our television screens if
that didn't work as a red line I don't
think any incidents like that would I
think problem is not enough people in
this country know 3.1 billion dollars of
their tax money goes directly to the
Israeli military without us support I
think it would be far harder not
impossible but much much more difficult
for Israel to maintain its belligerent
military occupation its policies of
apartheid its denial of the right of
return etc what makes all of that
possible is not only the u.s. money it
doesn't really need our charity but it
does need our protection at the United
Nations without that it would be held
accountable in the International
Criminal Court unfortunately I don't
think that we can anticipate that the
crisis in Gaza is likely to arc a
significant shift among the leaders of
the Arab countries
it certainly has reengaged people across
the Arab world where the question of
Palestine
even when it was not on the front burner
of the public demands of the Arab Spring
has remained a key component of what
motivates people to come into the street
[Music]